[Music]
ian is going to start us off in guam hi
ian how are you
good morning gentlemen half a day um
i'm doing well i was hoping that you and
john could help me today answering this
question um
currently in babysit 46 we have a paid
off car a family is growing and
i'm trying to find out how do we upgrade
a vehicle without going back into debt
and especially with this time but but
how do we do that
well i think you know
you have to save the money
yes so how do you get how do you save
the money i mean what what is your
income
uh currently about 90 000. that's good
so what is your current car worth
uh about it's estimated between 11 to 15
trade-in 11 to 15 is a pretty good range
so we probably can get 15 in this
current world that we live in okay so
let's call it 15. what are you upgrading
to what what kind of price range car
would you buy
so upgrading from a corolla to hopefully
a full-size suv
just with the amount of stuff that we
have
we're traveling the recipe you're doing
travel nursing so
we're trying to go back to this how much
money
currently saved up
no how much will the suv cost
about
25 to 35 that's our rank our budget is
25 35 so you don't have a budget you
don't have any money
you have a budget once you've got a
money right
yes okay well let's call it 25.
if you sell yours for 15 and you're
going to buy an suv for 25 you need 10
you make 90. how long does it take to
get 10 when you make 90.
pretty quick okay
that's how you do it
okay
i mean that was like some pin and teller
style magic right there dude
so brother where are you where are you
getting stuck something that that that
seems yeah
yeah i know i know it sounds it sounds
pretty silly no no i'm with you man i've
gotten stuck too just where are you
stuck what's what's what's messing with
you you got car fever for a car you
can't afford do you want to go buy it
today is that what's messing with you
um no it's just that um
our car is all the way in on the other
other side in maryland and we're trying
to
go you know closer to like washington or
wide but
my dilemma is we have to you know some
one of us will have to go in and trade
it in
or we can do online and it's just the
hassle of should we do online i should
just go back in person trade it in
because that's just you know a headache
for us as far as trying to upgrade and
using a vehicle you don't have a vehicle
in guam
right correct sorry that what was that
you don't have a car in guam right
we're renting a car okay
you're military i'm guessing
no travel nursing travel nursing okay so
you're renting a car in guam how long
are you going to stay in guam
until july okay
and so getting a car in guam is going to
cause a problem because you can turn
around and get rid of it right
or you're going to have to ship it
somewhere
yes and that's that's another issue that
well
it's not i'm not sure if we should keep
paying renting a car if when we move
back to the states or we should just get
our car that we have paid off where are
you going in july
uh it's up in the air right now because
it goes contract with contract so we can
decide where we want to go so we're
hoping either washington or hawaii one
of those two somewhere
but it's like i said it's up in the air
it's just we don't want to pay rental we
don't want to rent a car moving a car
from guam to hawaii would cost more than
the stupid car
yeah so we're not doing that right so
you're not going to buy a car that
you're going to keep for very long
if you buy a car in guam you're going to
turn right around and sell it in july
and if you wait until july somebody's
going to have a couple of three annoying
days because one of you is going to fly
out to
the east coast and deal with the car buy
a new one because you're going to have
cash by then you know what i would do
i'd keep my life real clean and real
simple you guys are making bank right
now because you're doing travel nursing
you're making you said you're making 90
is that all i'm making between the two
of you
um no just just my wife right now oh
okay what do you do
i'm a financial coach with dave ramsey
actually but
um
so that's my i'm just staying home and i
do my financial coaching
all right it's just that you need to get
on you need to get on a plane and go to
maryland and show your car
okay
and then when you get back with them
when you get back with the money you can
decide whether to buy a car in guam that
you're going to sell in july or whether
to rent from now until july and then
when you land in hawaii
uh or washington then you buy a car
got it yeah that's my plan it just took
me a minute to catch up with what was
stick getting you it's a long weekend
it's an annoying weekend or three days
just get on the plane and go sell your
car there's people who want to buy cars
like crazy right now there's a shortage
you can sell it in 20 minutes just you
know put it on
craigslist or trader.com or something
and and go ahead and get three buyers
lined up to look at it right after you
land at the airport drive over to where
it's sitting meet them there make sure
the batteries some one of your friends
went by and charge the battery and shine
the tires and uh sell the stupid thing
get back on plane go back home with a
pocket full of cash or have a friend who
you trust that you left the car with
have them get it detailed and then have
them sell it and tell me give them 500
bucks to the sale yeah be done yeah you
have them for taking care of it for you
give them give them a gift card to the
steakhouse i don't care whatever but
yeah it's just
uh
what's cause what's happening here it's
not really a car problem it's that you
all aren't you haven't you don't know
where you're gonna be
and once you know where you're to be
it's going to clear up all this but you
know you're not going to be in guam past
july so you know i'm not sure you buy a
car there i think you probably it's only
a couple months let's just keep renting
it i wouldn't screw with it but i'd go
and get that other one sold because
you're not going to use it either it's
just sitting over there put the money in
your pocket and buy a car when you land
yeah that's what i am gonna do i'm gonna
go and take it one step further don't
buy a car in guam nope absolutely not go
to the states sell your car or have your
friend do it for you one or two like
john said
and um rent until july and then when you
decide when you move to the next place
go buy a car
with cash
all right let's let's i want to walk
through this real quick okay okay uh we
got time for go to break
lots of variables lots of moving parts
that can be paralyzing it feels chaotic
in our heads and so we're just going ah
you're talking to a coach right that's
what he does for a living he helps other
people it just feels like a lot and what
you just did in quick form is all right
let's put all these variables down what
can i control i can sell that car i'm
gonna get on a plane it's gonna cost me
some money i'm gonna sell that car
number two i'm not gonna buy a car until
i know where i'm going number three
where we're going is is unknown cool i'm
just gonna sit with a pile of cash and
that's what i can control on this thing
and then the dust clears and let me just
tell you the the
stuck part the anxious part the stress
of all this as soon as you have your
little game plan laid out evaporates
goes away evaporates the ambivalence the
not knowing will kill you yes
you have to get a clear path
start checking boxes start walking down
the checklist before you take the
airplane off into the air it's every
pilot does that